we want to ask the question how should
we be teaching about climate change and
bruce i'm going to start with you on
this
should climate change be part of the
curriculum you're in the united states
at the moment what happens there at the
moment
so
um
this year has been the climate change
has been coming through the front door
like a battering ram right one in three
americans has been impacted by climate
change this year either super storms or
wildfires
and i have an eight-year-old daughter
she reads the headlines she understands
something is wrong and so it is critical
we help explain to our children science
of climate change why is it happening
and what do we need to do to solve it so
that they
as they become voters and actors in um
in the future that they are a part of
the solution and understand what we need
to do to help solve this problem so
education is absolutely critical i
didn't learn about climate change until
i went to university um that's too late
we need everyone including
our children in high school or grammar
school to be helping solve this problem
today
joyce what do you think about this
because i just want to show one
statistic to our viewers um one in five
children in the uk reports nightmares
about climate change i mean it's a
difficult subject to broach isn't it
with young children when
some of the news around it seems quite
scary
yeah and as bruce says children are
they're not you know they're not hidden
they're not um you know they they read
the news they understand what's going on
um and it's actually up to us the adults
the schools their parents to support
them on that journey and to be honest
with them about what is going on and why
it's happening and i think a huge part
of alleviating this anxiety is actually
taking action and being able to see
adults their leaders governments take
action um and actually
sit in their roles
of making positive change that is going
to be inspiring and that is going to be
empowering and it is going to take away
from this huge amount of fear that there
is right now because that fear is coming
um it's stemming a lot from this
helplessness and this overwhelm that
things aren't going to get better well
one way that children have actually
taken action that we've seen around the
world is these school strikes uh bruce i
mean do you approve of those there are
plenty of people here that worry that
children shouldn't be missing out on
vital education and missing days of
school and if they're gonna have their
voices heard why not do it at the
weekend
well so one of my most um
important memories of growing up was um
and similarly a a terrifying time during
um
the nuclear disarmament debate in the
1970s and 1980s one of the most
impactful things was going with my
church group down to london and hyde
park and and urging the government
uh to address the threat of nuclear
war
having children engaged to me was just a
critical step of understanding it and
also understanding that we can do
something about it so i'm a very big fan
of helping
inspiring children to get engaged in
civic engagement so that they can be a
part of shaping the future
and just another quick word from you on
that do you think children should be
allowed time off school to go on marches
or should they be spending time in the
classroom very briefly
yeah i don't think all education happens
in the classroom you have to get out
there you have to be part of it you have
to know what's going on in politics that
is also learning that is education for
them and so if that's what it takes to
get our leaders to make action and to
make children feel like they're part of
the solution then yeah i think it's uh
well worth the time okay well joyce
london and bruce nillis really good to
have you on the show thanks very much
indeed for joining us here tonight